still looking for a gift for that
special person on your valentine's day
list
we are here to help we visited lifestyle
consultant buffalo larry for some ideas
[Music]
here we are with buffalo larry lifestyle
expert and
tell everyone where we are buddy uh we
are in my latest venture
sonic rodeo down in the arts district
it's a multi-platform musician's
headquarters we
sell guitars amps instruments we repair
them we also have rehearsal studios
we can live stream performances record
larry you got some valentine's day gift
ideas for us what do you have
yeah um anybody who's seen any of these
segments before knows that i like
local handmade goods which brings me to
my friend nick's company fremont
leather um he makes these purses
uh my favorite my favorite wallet that
i've ever owned
uh you can have these things monogrammed
i think that's a great gift for a loved
one
uh in fact you consider me a loved one
larry gave me one of these
for for the holidays this wallet the
leather is so soft
and the thing i love about this too it
is the longer you have it it gets soft
but it also kind of folds too
hey is that like your body it's in your
back pocket molds to your uh
whichever pocket yeah whichever pocket
you're putting in and also too it's
small enough
you got my credit card there some cash
in there it's small enough uh it's not a
big bulky wallet but it still holds all
the items that you need how much you got
in there huh no you probably got more
than me you got your own recording
studio i'm just a tv guy
what do you have here um well i mean
what romantic night isn't complete with
music right so we have this portable
record player
um you can take this wherever you want
it's rechargeable it has its own
speakers
uh there's just something better about
music on vinyl buffalo larry's
selection this is gonna go great with
your record players nice a lot of
records no record player this is perfect
then uh these hunks
the rhyolite sound that guy kind of
looks like you he does handsome
jc welcome to the nashville room at
sonic rodeo dude that was cool
and this room is even cooler man thank
you very much this is the uh the crown
jewel the whole establishment
um this is a great place to uh let that
loved one of yours get out of the house
and
you know make a lot of noise perfect
this is band rehearsals down here and
you were telling me something about
karaoke as well
yeah uh we will rent the room out for
karaoke parties we'll we'll set it up
for you um
there's a comfortable lounge area and
it's a safe way to have a lot of fun
yeah it's a great vibe back here
thanks i got one more thing to show you
outside before we go i always wanted to
do this hold on a second
[Music]
larry you got me a tesla you betcha
what's the backstory on this
uh we rented this through touro which is
an app that's basically the airbnb of
luxury and exotic cars
i've heard about this app they have
everything from tesla's muscle cars
all kinds of vehicles which is perfect
if you're doing valentine's day dinner
do it in class
how did you get the car down here uh
they actually dropped it off to me
this morning this is gorgeous yeah for a
couple of days yeah
we're gonna do this take for spin get
some dinner maybe let's do it we'll do
our own valentine's day dinner this
thing is beautiful do you know how to
shut the doors
i do this thing's like a spaceship
absolutely
you can rent teslas you can rent camaros
all kinds of cars with that tour right
but it is so neat all right las vegas
now